we will Brazil  we will presents  [Music]  I'm from India Kerala well lots of a  good place actually we love them  especially Neymar from long time with  Ronaldo and this kind of  players this time they have a good team  and the Philippines they will win  I'm from Solomon Islands we have a  massive following of Brazil back home  where they have all the superstars right  now to win this tournament and I think I  think they can go all the way and win  the final 100 it's very enjoying good  you see projects  [Music]  it's interesting because we were talking  about this like international support  it's very interesting to see like we  have already won the the works of like  five times so maybe I mean it's a lot  exactly  [Music]  all right  [Applause]